inge grèce je me tourne vers vous est ce
que vous attendez vous d'alexis ty braz
qu'il révolutionne l'union européenne
pas du tout pas du tout je me soucie
comment va-t-on faire avec le peuple
grèce qui a voté on respecte ce vote on
met ce vote est basé sur tant de
promesses fausse de mensonges même et
aussi des attentes fausse c'est pour ça
qu'il faut maintenant tout faire pour
calmer un peu le jeu en grèce on a des
accords et nous on a pris des garanties
sur la base de ces accords là sur la
base des promesses d'être fiable à ces
accords là et maintenant je peux pas
dire voilà maintenant on a changé
d'hommes d'opinion il changé d'avis nous
on peut pas changer d'avis quand on
traverse une fleuve et on est au milieu
on est au milieu et je dois vous dire
que les locaux dont ils valorisent et
l'intention de conclure que vous les
décrivez les sentais incroyablement d'or
c'est vrai mais je dois vous dire que
vous dites n'est pas vrai sur le passé
vous savez mon problème c'est que il y a
des bases légales pour tous on a pris on
a pris des
garanties importantes
le gouvernement allemand est lié par ces
garanties par cette base légale elle
peut pas en sortir quand ça vous arrange
le droit c'est quand ça vous arrange ça
que je trouve ça très irresponsable que
vous faites quand vous faites semblant
comme si on change ça très facilement il
faut rediscuter c'est la politique
madame c'est pas le droit qui nous
gouvernent comme ça c'est la solitude le
20 février lors de vérité c'est la
dernière tranche du day2 deuxième paquet
pour tête pour la grèce elle rappelle
comptable madame responsabilié quand
signé ces accords la connaît s'ils ont
ainsi un signe clair pas de 30